30 €10 no 10 euro troppo poco 20 quindi
dai 15 bellissimo originale Dai va bene
fare 10 solo perché sei tuo amico fascia
con lana pinza cappello bandana a
pallone tu compra una e paghi uno tu
compra tre banditi capo tuo essere
stilosissimo io confidarti questo
occhiale Guarda che bello stilosissimo
Tu vuoi andare a comandare così sposati
o fidanzati sposati Allora bella la
moglie a fare belle le regole del marito
sono marito si fa fare belli regali da
altre bella signora comprare Bella borsa
Tu potrai mettere dentro tantissime cose
e soldi trucchi crema anche amanti lui
amante Allora borsa troppo piccola
comprare una più grande tu dirai sempre
tu vieni dopo io comprare io passare
ogni volta tu non comprare mai non si fa
così bella signora ma fa cattiva con me
Mustafà però Bravo quindi regalare
questa bella signora questa collana
Azzurra colore ai suoi occhi €20 signora
no io non avere detto regalo io avrei
detto regalo e che fare €20 invece di 55
pietra preziosa eh argento